what's up believe nation today and when
I share with you my favorite top ten
rules to success April 2017 edition and
as always guys as people are talking if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
count's below put quotes around it as
well so other people can be inspired and
when you're writing something down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy so hard and then when you
think you're going hard go harder like
that's really it just hustle you know I
mean there's nothing like that you can't
you can't put enough work in every
single day and not get better at you
know what I mean like if you want to be
good at something you know I mean like
you can't just like not like do it every
day and not get better with music the
same learn how to play an instrument or
something if you spend your time
practicing your craft like you know
that's really it's just you know because
nowadays like with the internet
everything is so accessible and you know
everybody in the world is a rapper you
know what I mean everybody's putting
music out so it's like how do you stand
out quality is always gonna matter but
also being different you can't try to be
different I mean but you just gotta be
yourself what's the biggest risk you've
taken that you feel is paid off the
biggest risk I've taken that has paid I
want to say cookie I mean I was very
nervous when I received this script um
she wasn't the most likable character
and I've played some pretty edgy
characters but this one was particularly
a challenge because it was primetime
Network television and I wasn't sure how
people would receive her I mean she beat
her son with a broom even though he
deserved it um she called once on a
[ __ ] I mean it was it was scary but
I'm the type of artist that if the role
doesn't scare me I don't want it because
it's not gonna change me as a person so
I took a risk and that's what you do as
artists you jump in feet
and you see where it goes and I knew
that we had something special
I don't just jump feet first for any
project I knew this was something
special I knew that what Fox was trying
to do with Lee Daniels and tani strong
we're trying to do and what I was trying
to do was shake up television it's too
safe you know life is not safe and I
think we did that with this show so I'm
so proud to be a part of this project
and I'm so proud that Fox believed in us
and took a chance because that's what
art is about isn't it taking chance
that's taking risks yeah I think if you
don't actually believe what you're doing
is really important if you don't derive
satisfaction from what you're doing then
you will not be able to sustain all of
the bad things that happen an incredibly
long period of time that the bad things
happen over and so the only motivation
that I have seen work for people over a
long period of time is enjoyment and
what they're doing and an intense belief
that it matters and ideally liking the
people that they go to work with every
day um but the I think the reasons that
a lot of people and by the way it's
totally cool when people start off
saying well I want to make money or I
want to be famous I think a lot of
people start that way and they don't
like to admit it but pretty quickly or
at least in the first few years I think
a lot of people find a deeper mission
for why they do what they do and that
that drives them then for the rest of
the time they work I look around at my
girlfriends and my my guy friends and
they're in jobs that they don't really
have a lot of growth potential in that
they're not passionate about and I think
if we're ever going to make all
decisions it has to be at this point in
our life you know we have to be out
there we have to be experimenting we
have to be looking for that which makes
us tick and I think a big part of that
evolution for me was really summer jobs
working and making sure to actually you
know get into the world and try
different things and eliminate those
which is as useful eliminating those
career paths that you're not interested
in as it is
you know doing things that that do
interest you but I think just being bold
and and taking risks when you're young
is so important because I can't imagine
working the hours that I do if I didn't
fundamentally love it and I think that's
the difference between somebody's
successful and somebody that's extremely
successful somebody that's good and
somebody that's exceptionally good it's
the level of Drive which directly stems
from passion different types of people
in this world and one thing that we're
all going to deal with is like
difficulties in our tasks trying to
become successful as good as things get
you have the same amount of bad that's
going to try to impede your progress
whether it be people whether it be the
IRS whether it be whatever something
will rear its ugly head and try to block
you now a lot of people can't handle -
when you have a vision and something or
someone throws a curveball it hurts
things right it's like your baby and now
I can't put my baby out there like I
want to do it so it really throws people
off that you can negatively maybe the
president might want to stop they might
want to just go back to their 9:00 to
5:00 that's fine is not for everybody to
push through but for those who camp was
- like he said the difference between
those who really succeed don't are the
ones who when they're faced with
whatever it is difficult these are
they're like I'm going to keep pushing
through i'ma keep pushing through
because there's some corny and cliche
but it's always sunshine after the rain
you're gonna be saying rain don't last
that long
you got to know that be aware that
that's something you can take me to do
with everything in life but in business
you cannot stop because they said I want
to write at the time because it's gonna
happen I'll deal with it
I'm sure doing it again at some point
the number one thing that's gonna change
your life
the only thing that will change your
life change your business change your
money change your relationship because
you must raise your standard I know that
sounds boring stupid basic but it's the
truth the only thing that changes our
life long term
is when we raise our standards what does
that mean that sounds so boring and dumb
it means that all of us in life have
things we want we don't get what we want
we get what we have to have remember I
said earlier we all get what we tolerate
in ourselves and other people but when
you're no longer willing to tolerate
something that's when your life changes
the difference in people is their
standards period the difference in
people is their standards period and
what I mean by standards everyone in the
world has a list of things they think
they should do I should lose weight I
should work out I should spend more time
with my kids I should work harder I
should make more calls I should I should
I should I should and then you know what
people don't do their sheds and they get
mad at themselves and they when I call
[ __ ] all over themselves they beat
themselves up about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should happen has to happen
that's when human beings change it's
like if you want to take the island and
you're the head of the army and you want
to take the Arendt Island the most
powerful way to take the Islanders burn
the boats cuz if there's no way to go
back it's amazing what happens when it's
a must to do something versus a [ __ ]
that's what makes human being succeed if
you want to be a fireman go and do it
you want to be a ballet dancer than
gonna be a ballet dancer if you don't
believe in yourselves and no one else
will believe in you and yeah it's an
important from it's so important for me
to people to understand that I want to
be an inspiration I was believed as
9 out of 10 Georgian are and I want it I
want to be a role model I think now I'm
in the kind of limelight to go it's okay
and it's the special people got a
billiard you know the ones that have
something magical and it's something
that you can turn into a positive and
not let it eat you away and there'll
always be someone that says you can't do
it there'll always be someone that says
I don't believe in you there'll always
be someone that says I do believe in you
and there's always something that says
you can do it and that's the people you
have to focus on oh you're much
beautiful try and put me down which they
do when they say you know every time I
hear you song I want to burn my ears I
say there's nothing that but I said what
if finally comes down to in your
business and how you run it is you first
in me second take that home with you you
first and me second the first thing you
want to do is help your people succeed
and then you see just keep it in the
right order it's not you succeeding and
then hopefully they come out okay it's
all about them not about you and I think
that was the foundation of our business
you know we never Jay and I never talked
about how much money we made or how much
money we wanted to make we talked about
big we like ever business but it was
never a personal financial goal but our
focus was on how we could enrich the
lives of our people and make them better
oftentimes influencing them with our
faith as well I feel a genuine need to
communicate with an audience and it
might just be the attention I didn't get
as a kid I can't come from anything good
but what I try and do is bring the best
information I can to the stage and and
broadcast it so I'm it's reportage from
distant points from a fairly unique
standpoint and so basically I'm not
keeping it all to myself but I earnestly
try to us not about entertainment it's
about communication warning broadcasting
omitting and trying to leave something
of myself with these with the audience
not just not mere entertainment
not just making people laugh or not it's
it's got to hurt me it's got to leave
lines in my face I don't like any
artistic endeavor that doesn't extol a
price on the one doing it so I'm not
looking to get through these things okay
these things are actually very difficult
and very hard on my psyche which makes
me think I'm doing the right thing blue
came out with a product in 2000 in 1980
a product that was based on an
innovation to introduce rubble as a
strap
it seems very common today but rubber in
1980 was a real courageous move it was
even the provocation people said hey on
a gold watch rubber because people
didn't know rubber comes from a tree
rubber is natural rubber is is very
comfortable it's very flexible and
rubber is very resistant and it's
waterproof so finally it's ideal for
what but in those days it's people
thought it's a provocation it's a and
then we blue could not evolve they
stayed on a product and I said we are
not a product we have a message first we
have a concept and the concept is fusion
why because in 1980 when we put gold
together with rubber we created a fusion
because golden rubber never come
together they were together only one
time in life during the Big Bang then
everything was in one and then rubber go
it went away and said okay I go now on
my tree and God said okay I go and rest
in South Africa under the earth and
since then they never met till people
take them and connect them so I said you
know made a fusion and fusion must be
our message must be our philosophy must
be our religion and once we have this
religion
and it is named fusion then we can
develop further products that not
necessarily need the rubber anymore
because fusion goes further away than
just rubber it can be carbon it can be
ceramic whatever so I was capable to
free you blue from the product and give
you blue a message and from that message
new products were born and that was the
most important element in the revival of
the brand it's to take it away from a
product concept and to give it a brand
message and from the brand message where
then later born in 2005 new products
when you finish a film your job
basically is over and when you you have
a desire to share your work and so you
put it out into the world and you
realize that yes you can help the film
some by giving interviews or you can go
to some places and and have talks but
basically the film is on its own and you
can't tell whether it's going to go good
or going to go bad if it's important
that you believe in your work and and
that's the most important thing I
watched so many metals in my life
unbelievable and they're really not so
there are some boring games and then I
was asleep and it's so boring I think
while they meet each other and make this
20 40 50 60 70 80 thousand people in a
stadium on this boring game it's not
okay so that's what we what we want to
see we want to enjoy our own game if we
lose okay we like to win but if we lose
with our way it's okay if we lose with
the way of somebody else it's it's
you cannot work with this so that's it
it's very emotional
very fast very strong not boring no
chess like this no yes of course
tactical yes but a detective with with
big heart and Tek to you things are so
important you cannot win without
technical things but the the the emotion
make the difference life in our in our
game that's important right gave us talk
to a group of entrepreneurs and this one
woman raised her hand she knows well
you're real positive but what do you do
what do you tell yourself when you've
just wasted a year and a half of your
life doing something and it didn't work
out and I told her that's a real
negative way of looking at it I did that
I do why you can you rephrase the
question and then ask me again because
it's just you're looking at it really
negatively up first of all so I'd anyone
answer it that way so yeah she's not
about as you said well I'd learned an
important lesson the hard way I said
that still sucks no wonder you don't
want to move forward because you feel
like you've done something wrong because
it didn't work out the way you had
predetermined you wanted it to work out
you have to look at it a different way
if you feel like you want to do
something you should just step forward
it may not work but you're gonna hit a
step in your career and in your
development that you could not have
taken had you not gone that way before
you can get over there and I say in the
ashes of all your failures if you look
close enough you'll find keys to success
if you're a very negative person all you
would focus on is wow I have a really
bad movie on my resume that I wish I had
never done but if you're a positive
person you'll go I'm so glad I took that
step that most people would not have
taken because that got me to a place
that no one else can follow thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think what was your
favorite clip what are you gonna take
from this video and immediately apply to
your life for your business somehow
leave it down the comments below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to RZA Pereira
thank you so much RZA for picking up a
copy of my book your one word really
really really reads a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever
your one word is much loved I'll see you
soon